Welcome, it is time for Drew's News.
We cast out our line,
and we reel in that good old news tuna,
catch a keepa, and with me at the desk
is my chicken of the sea, Ross Matthews.
Yeah, you got a big one, hi, hi.
(audience cheering)
Okay, well, first up,
I found this story to be a total delight.
Our favorite girl, Dakota Johnson, that's right,
her and I do the "Little Yellow Book",
and her company TeaTime, we curate lists together.
So, she's a dear friend of our show,
and she just revealed one of her favorite hobbies.
"People" reports that Dakota says in her spare time,
she loves to crash weddings.
What?
How fun is that?
I just re-watched "Wedding Crashers" this weekend to,
so I was primed for this.
One time she said she was holding up a bride and groom
in a chair, I mean, one Hava Nagila, I love it.
And they look down and they were like,
"Oh, whoa, what are you doing here?"
Dakota, you little minks, I love this about you.
All your layers, come crash our show
or a wedding anytime soon.
Have you ever crashed anything Rossi?
I would never crash a wedding in my life,
especially since I'm planning one now.
All I'm thinking to myself is like, that's three shrimp.
That's three shrimp, right?
We plan ahead.
Hey, what about this?
There's a big trend on TikTok, did you see this?
About finding your main character energy?
It's all about being the star of the film of your life.
Well, "Well + Good" reports there's also a ton of value
in celebrating something they call
"Supporting Character Energy", right.
'Cause we all wanna be J.Lo, I know we do,
but sometimes you gotta be Judy Greer.
Oh, I love Judy Greer so much.
It's okay to be the Ron Weasley and not the Harry Potter,
you understand?
Like, and I feel like I get to do that for you.
Like I'm here to help support you.
And I love being your little supporting actor.
(audience cheering)
I mean...
You do.
It's funny, I always think of the word co you know,
like I think of us as total equals,
and I will be your supporting girl any day of the week.
Oh, I love you.
Flower girl, your Charlotte.
I'm just so happy to be in it with you.
And so I love you, and you are the starring character.
I'm your supporting girl.
I love you too.
Well, Spring is in the air, but one town in England
has carpeted flowers in the town thanks to one man.
The "Good News Network" reports that more
than 100,000 daffodils are blooming in Sidmouth, okay.
They're a gift from banker, Keith Owen.
He passed in 2007 and he left his life savings
to the local conservation group
to grow a million flowers over time,
I wonder who's counting?
Every year, volunteers plant bulbs around Sidmouth,
and the town, that's the town where his mother lived.
I mean, whoa.
I know
This one just gets me
because I grew up in Washington state,
and we are known for our tulip festivals and our daffodils.
And my mom always had them in the front yard,
and they still, you know because they're perennials,
they come up every year.
So even though she's no longer here, they still come up.
And even though this man's no longer there,
they still come up.
And just this morning, it's so funny,
I didn't know we were gonna talk about this story,
but just this morning I walked outside of my new house
that I got here, and there's like some snow still
in the corner, but there's some daffodils popping up.
So I just felt like maybe it was a sign from my mom.
And then to see this story,
it just makes me feel so wonderful that there's, you know,
Oh my God.
Life goes on, you know.
Last night I was scrolling Instagram
and I felt like I really needed something,
and I was scrolling and scrolling and scrolling,
and I come up across a quad picture of my grandmother
Dolores Costello, on "Old Hollywood Fans",
one of my favorite Instagram accounts,
and she's there, and I just started hysterically crying.
So keep your eyes open,
and something will eventually come up.
That's a great sign that things are going to be okay,
and they are okay, 'cause they'll come.
They come.
It really will.
When you need them, they come.
Yes, absolutely.
I needed this today.
(upbeat music)